[SQEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER:
Welcome, everyone,
back to theory of computation.
So we are now at
lecture number 15.
And this is an
important lecture.
Well, all of our
lectures are important,
but this is going to introduce
one of the major topics
that we're going to see
going on in various forms
through the rest of
the semester, which
is the notion of a
complete problem.
In this case, it's going to
be an NP complete problem.
And I think some of you have
probably heard of that concept
already.
Maybe you've seen it in
some courses or other,
but we're going to do that in
a rather careful and formal way
over the next
couple of lectures.
So we are following up on
our previous discussions
about complexity,
time complexity.
We defined the time and not
deterministic time complexity
classes, as you may
remember, the classes P
and NP, talked about
the P versus NP problem,
looked at some
interesting algorithms
for showing problems in P
called dynamic programming.
And we started to move
toward our discussion of NP
completeness with the
introduction of polynomial time
reducibility, which is
related to some of the earlier
reducibility notions
that we discussed
in the computability section.
Quick review-- what it means
for one problem to be polynomial
time reducible to another--
this follows our pattern
of reducibility concepts,
where if a problem is
reducible to another problem,
and that other
problem is solvable,
then the first
problem is solvable.
So if a problem is reducible
to an easy problem,
that problem
becomes [INAUDIBLE]..
And the kind of
reduction that we're
going to be looking at here
are the mapping reductions,
but now where the reductions are
computable in polynomial time.
And so we had this
result we mentioned
last time, that, if A is
polynomial time reducible to B,
and B is in P, then
A is also in P.
So that's going to be critically
important for the whole
of discussion that's coming.
Our intuition about P and
NP, repeating that here--
the NP problems are the ones
where you can verify membership
easily, as opposed to being
able to test membership easily.
Those are the problems
that are in P.
The verification
typically requires
some kind of a certificate
that establishes
a proof that the input is
a member of that language.
And the big question
of the field,
which remains an
unsolved problem,
is whether P equals NP.
It's called the P
versus NP question.
And we don't know the answer--
so whether there are problems
that are in NP solvable
in non-deterministic
polynomial time--
typically these are problems
that involve searching--
whether they can be
solved in polynomial time,
typically without the searching.
And if P were equal
to NP, then you
could always
eliminate searching.
And if P were different
from NP, then there
were cases where
you need to search.
And we don't know
the answer to that.
So in the direction of
exploring this question
and its ramifications,
we introduced
this problem called SAT.
These are the Boolean formulas,
which have an assignment that
makes them evaluate to true.
So we call those
satisfiable formulas.
And we mentioned, but
have not yet proven--
and we will not prove until
the next lecture on Tuesday--
that there is this theorem,
a very remarkable theorem
that says that, if you have--
take the satisfiability problem,
and if it is solvable quickly,
then all of the NP problems
are solvable quickly.
So if SAT is in P,
then P equals NP.
So in a sense, SAT
is kind of no the--
it's sort of the
super NP problem,
in the sense that all of the
difficulty of any NP problem
is embedded within SAT.
So if SAT becomes easy, then
all of the other NP problems
become easy.
And we'll eventually
prove that, but right now
we're setting up the terminology
to allow us to do that.
So anyway, we'll get there.
So the key ingredient for
proving this Cook-Levin theorem
is polynomial time reducibility.
What we're going to show
is that every problem in NP
can be polynomial
time reduced to SAT.
So every NP problem can be
converted into a SAT problem.
And so working toward
that-- because when
you think about it, there are
infinitely many primes in NP,
and being able to show that all
of them are reducible to SAT
is, in a sense, kind of-- you
have to prove a higher level
theorem.
It's not just a
single reduction.
We're exhibiting a
schema of reductions,
which shows that all of these
problems can be reduced to SAT.
And developing our intuition
toward that direction,
we're going to look at some
specific polynomial time
reductions today.
And we'll start out with a
reduction between two problems
we have not yet seen--
one of them called 3SAT and
the other one called clique.
So on this slide, we're going
to introduce those two problems.
So remembering, again,
about Boolean formulas,
we're going to consider
a special class
of Boolean formulas, restricted
form of Boolean form formulas
called conjunctive normal form.
And so this formula
here in particular
is in that conjunctive
normal form.
So just remember--
I was explaining some
of this to someone else
earlier this morning,
showing some of these slides,
and it was pointed out
that not all of you
may be familiar with these
the Boolean operations of
and and or.
So this is the or symbol here.
This is the and symbol here.
Hopefully you've seen just the
concept of Booelan and and or.
Or is, in a sense, a
little bit like a union.
And it's like an intersection.
And the symbols here are a
little bit similar to the union
and the intersection--
union and intersection
symbols themselves.
The V shape is a little bit
like a pointy union symbol an
the upside down V
shape is a little like
a pointy intersection symbol.
If you haven't seen those--
seen that connection
before, maybe it's
interesting to observe that.
But anyway, what
makes this formula
be in conjunctive normal form?
Well, conjunctive
normal formulas
are organized in a certain way.
They have these
groups called clauses
within the parentheses
that are anded together,
that are connected by
these and operations.
And within those groups,
which are called clauses,
the elements are ORed together.
Those elements are going
to be either variables
or variables with negation,
negated variables.
So just to repeat that, these--
well, just to state, those
variables or negated variables
are going to be called
literals, and the ORs
of a bunch of literals are
going to be called clauses.
This is just the standard
terminology in the field.
OK?
So a literal is a variable
or a negated variable
and a clause is an
or of literals--
just a definition.
All right, so we have a
bunch of these clauses here.
Each of the clauses has
an or of literals in it.
Now, a Chomsky--
Chomsky-- conjunctive
normal form formula--
I guess they're both CNFs--
but conjunctive
normal form formula
is one that's written as
an and of these clauses.
So we take these clauses,
which themselves are ORs--
we and them together,
we get a formula
that's conjunctive normal form.
Conjunctive stands
for and, I think.
Conjunction is an and.
And then a 3CNF is a CNF where
each clause has exactly three
literals.
So for example, this
particular formula is a CNF,
but it's not a 3CNF, because it
has at least two clauses which
violate the condition of
three literals per clause.
This one is OK, obviously--
this first clause.
And a 3SAT problem--
so this is the first
of the two problems
we're going to be
talking about--
the 3SAT problem is the
satisfiability problem
restricted to these
3CNF formulas.
So this is the collection of--
set of 3CNF formulas
which are satisfiable.
So you can think of it as kind
of a special case of the SAT
problem, where we only
care about formulas
of the special kind.
This being a special
case, you might
imagine that this might be
an easier problem to solve,
but in general, it turns out
not to be, as we will see.
Solving this special
case is just as hard
as hard as solving the general
case for satisfiability.
Now let's turn to the second
of these two languages
up in the headline,
the clique problem.
So for that we--
going to turn to graph theory.
So we're going to
consider graphs, points
and lines-- connecting them.
And we will say that
a clique in a graph
is a collection of nodes--
collection of the points
that are all pairwise
connected by lines.
And a k-clique is one where
you have k such nodes.
So here we have a three clique,
four clique, and a five clique.
And then the clique
problem is to try
to find cliques of a certain
specified size embedded
within a given graph.
You're going to
be given a graph,
and it targets clique sized
k, and you want to know,
is there a subset of the
nodes in the graph of size k
that are all connected
to one another?
That's the clique problem.
So obviously, the clique
problem, just as with
the satisfiability problem,
is a decidable problem.
You can just try every
possible subset of k nodes
and see whether it
constitutes a clique.
But that's, in general, going
to be an exponential algorithm.
If you have-- k
is a large value--
it might be half the size of
the graph-- you might be looking
for a very large clique.
Then you have to try many,
many subsets in order
to see whether any one
of them is a clique.
It's also going to be and--
I hope you get this intuition--
this is a problem that's in NP.
The clique problem
is an NP problem,
because you can easily verify
that a graph has a k-clique
just by exhibiting the clique.
OK.
Now, so the language here is
you've given a graph and a k,
and you want to know, does
the graph contain a k-clique?
And what we're going to show
is that these two problems
are connected, that the 3SAT
problem on the clique problem
are related, in that you can
reduce in polynomial time 3SAT
to clique.
Just standing back at it--
back for a minute, it
seems kind of surprising.
There's no real reason--
no obvious reason
why there should
be a connection between
three 3SAT and clique.
They look very different
from one another.
But we do give that--
we will give that reduction.
That implies that,
if you can find
a way of solving the
clique problem quickly,
that'll give you a way
of solving the 3SAT
problem quickly.
And that's going to be
the whole point of this.
So we're going to show
this over the next slide
or two, this polynomial
time reduction.
I'm going to walk
through it slowly,
but this is one where it's
really important to try
to get a sense of
how it's working,
because this is
the kind of thing
that we're going to
be doing a lot of,
and you're going to be asked
to do it also on the homework
and possibly on the final exam.
I hate to use that as the
motivating force here,
but at least it might be one
motivation for some of you,
that you have to understand how
to do this kind of a reduction.
I think, at a high
level, what's going
on is we're showing how to
recode a Boolean formula
satisfiability problem
into the problem of testing
whether a graph has a clique.
Oh, let's see if we
have any questions here
that are coming up in the chat.
OK, so this is an
interesting question here.
Can we always convert
a Boolean formula
into conjunctive normal
form, first of all?
Yes.
The answer is you can always
convert a Boolean formula
into an equivalent one in CNF.
But in general, that
might make the formula
exponentially larger.
So just the mere fact that
you can convert formulas
into conjunctive
normal form doesn't
mean that solving
conjunctive normal form
formulas for testing
satisfiability of the CNF
formulas is going to be as hard
as testing the general case,
because just the conversion
might be exponential.
There's something more--
little bit more complicated
going on than that.
Let me just see here.
If phi is a satisfiable with
formula which is not in CNF,
can be--
so a similar question-- so
the questions that I'm getting
are about converting
formulas to CNF.
So yeah, you can do it, but not
in polynomial time, in general,
because the resulting formula
you get might be much larger--
if you're looking for
an equivalent formula.
If you're not looking for an
equivalent formula, then--
of course, then, depending
upon what you're looking for,
you might be able to
find something smaller.
This is, I guess, a
good basic question.
Why is clique in NP?
Doesn't verifying
that you have a clique
require going through
all the possible cliques?
You have to understand
what verifying means.
Verifying means you
can verify something
if you're given a certificate.
In the case of a clique--
the clique problem-- the
certificate is the clique.
So once you have
the certificate,
you can do the verification
in polynomial time.
Finding the certificate, of
course, might be difficult.
So you only think
of NP in the context
of having that certificate.
So in a case for
compositeness, the certificate
might be the factor.
There are problems sometimes
where what the certificate is
is not necessarily obvious.
But there can be a certificate
for showing that the input is
in the language.
In the ones that
we've done so far,
maybe you can argue
that the certificate is
sort of an obvious thing,
but it's not always
an obvious thing.
OK.
Why don't we move on then?
So let's see, how do we do
this polynomial time reduction
from 3SAT to clique?
OK, here we go.
So I'm just going
to give a reduction.
That's what the
definition means.
I'm going to give a way
of converting formulas
to pairs, a G and a k,
where the formula's going
to be satisfiability if and only
if the graph has a k-clique.
OK, so let's a little
bit do it by example.
And in order to do that--
so here's going to
be a formula now.
It's in 3CNF.
That's what I need in order
to be doing this reduction.
I'm converting 3CNF formulas
into clique problems.
We to have a little
bit understand
what it means when we say--
we talk about the satisfiability
of a formula like this,
because it's going to be
helpful in doing the reduction.
Obviously, satisfiability
means that the--
you can find an assignment
to the variables.
So you're going to set
each of these variables--
A, B, and C, and so
on-- to true or false,
and you want to make the whole
formula evaluate the true.
But what does that
actually mean?
It means that, because of the
structure of the formula, that
making this formula true
corresponds to making
each clause true--
because the clauses
are all anded together,
so the only way for
the formula to be true
is to make each clause true.
And to make a clause true,
you have to make at least one
of the literals true.
So it's another way of thinking
about satisfying this formula.
Satisfying these [INAUDIBLE]
satisfying assignment
makes at least one true
literal in every clause.
It's really important to
think about it that way,
because that's
what's going to be
the basis for doing
this reduction
and all of the reductions.
It's what makes 3SAT
easy to think about,
in terms of its satisfiability.
If you had a general
satisfiability problem
and you had a
satisfiability both formula,
there's no obvious way of seeing
what the satisfying assignment
looks like, but here we
understand what it looks like.
It has that very special
form, making one true literal
in every clause-- at least one
true literal in every clause.
So now we're going
to do the reduction.
So I'm going to take
from this formula--
I know, for some of you,
you're going to be chafing.
Why am I going slowly?
But I want to make
sure that we're
all together and understanding
what the rules of the game are
and what we're trying to do.
We're trying to
convert this formula
into a graph and a number.
So right now my job is,
to do this reduction,
is to exhibit that graph.
So I'm going to do
that and two steps.
First, I'm going to tell you
what the nodes of the graph
are.
Then I'll tell you what the
edges of that graph [AUDIO OUT]
Finally, I'll tell you
what the number k is.
That's the way this
polynomial time
reduction is going to work.
And we have to also observe at
the very end that the reduction
that I'm given--
giving you, this procedure
for building this graph
can be done in polynomial
time, but that, I
think-- you'll
see, once I'm done,
that that's pretty obvious.
OK, so first, as I
promised, the nodes--
so the nodes of
this graph are going
to correspond to the
literals of the formula.
Every literal is going to
become a node in the graph,
and it's going to be labeled
with the name of that literal.
Every node is going
to be labeled an a,
a b, or c bar, and so on.
So here it goes.
So those are the
nodes of the graph
G, one for each literal in the
formula, labeled as promised.
Now I have to tell you
what the edges look like.
I'm going to tell you what the
edges are by first telling you
what they are not.
I'm going to first
explain to you
what the forbidden
edges are, what
edges I'm going to
promise not to include.
And then the ones
that I will include
are going to be all the others.
So what are going to
be the forbidden edges?
First of all, the
forbidden edges
are going to be of two types.
One is the edges between
nodes that come from literals
in the same clause.
So I would just call that
no edges within a clause.
So for example,
these three nodes
will not be connected
to one another.
And I'm going to
indicate that by writing
red dashed lines, which means
there's not an edge there.
Those are forbidden
from having an edge.
So these three have no
edge, and the same thing
for every other triple of three
nodes that come from clauses.
Those are no edges there.
And there's one other category
of edge that I'm forbidding,
and that are edges that can--
that go between inconsistent
labels, and the nodes
with inconsistent labels.
So for example,
between a and a bar--
those are inconsistent.
Nothing's wrong
with a going a to d.
Those are not inconsistent.
Those are just different labels.
Or going from a
to a-- that's OK.
But from a to a bar--
that's not allowed.
So that's going to be
another forbidden edge--
or for example, a to a bar here,
a bar to a, or for example,
from this c bar to c--
forbidden.
OK?
So you imagine, you're
going to write down
all of those forbidden edges.
Those are all of
the forbidden edges,
and then, after
taking those away,
you're going to be putting in
all the other edges possible.
So for example-- let me
just gray those out so they
don't interfere
with the picture--
from a to d, there's going to be
an edge, because those are not
forbidden.
a to a-- not forbidden,
because they--
they're in different clauses
and they're not inconsistent.
They're consistent
with one another.
So here are a whole
bunch of others.
I'm not showing them all.
It becomes very messy.
But here are all of the other
edges between nodes which are--
where they're not forbidden.
OK?
And that's the graph.
That's G. G is all those
nodes and those edges which
are not forbidden.
And I just have to
tell you what k is.
k is going to be the
number of clauses.
That's going to be the
size of the clique I'm
looking for in this graph G
that I just spelled out for you.
And I'm going to claim that
this graph here that I just
described will have a k-clique.
k is the number of clauses
exactly when phi was satisfied.
It's kind of cool.
If phi is satisfiability, then
there will be a k-clique here.
And if phi was not
satisfiability-- no k-clique.
We're going to prove that as
a claim on the next slide.
OK, so k is the
number of clauses.
All right?
Any questions on
that construction?
So I've done with
the construction.
What's left is to argue
why the construction works.
So far, so good-- let's move on.
OK.
So here is that very
same construction.
I eliminated the
red forbidden edges.
These are the ones
that were remaining,
plus anything else
that was not forbidden.
That was the same formula that
I had from the previous slide.
Now I want to claim that that
formula is satisfiability
exactly when G has a k-clique.
Now, why in the world is that?
So this is an if and only if.
It's proved in both directions.
And this is going to be
the typical kind of thing
that you're going to want to
do when you're exhibiting a--
one of these reductions,
which is you're
going to have an
opportunity to do that.
And we'll do that
too in our examples.
OK, so now what
I want to show is
that, if phi is
satisfiable-- so let's
prove the forward direction--
if phi is satisfiable,
then G has a k-clique.
OK, so first of all,
if phi is satisfiable,
that means it has a
satisfying assignment.
Now, here's a common confusion.
I'm not sure whether
it's helpful to sprinkle
the confusions alone
with the discussion,
but in case you're worried,
you might ask, well,
how do I find that
satisfying assignment?
I thought that was
exponentially hard to do.
This is a proof.
This is not an algorithm.
We're just trying to
argue the correctness
of this construction.
So there's no longer
any concern about how
to find an assignment.
I'm just saying, if there
is an assignment-- if there
is a satisfying
assignment, then something
will happen something.
Then something will
happen-- in particular,
then we will show
that G has a k-clique.
So let's say phi is satisfiable,
so it has some assignment.
Let's take that
satisfying assignment.
And remember that, in
any satisfying assignment
to a formula in CNF, that
makes at least one literal true
in every clause.
So let's just pick one of those.
There might be
several clauses which
have multiple true literals.
In that case, just pick
one of them arbitrarily.
I don't have this indicated
on this diagram here,
but imagine maybe, in the
very first clause, a was true;
in the second clause, b was
true; in the third clause,
e complement-- e bar
was true, not e--
e bar was true, which
means e itself was false,
but e bar was true.
And that's the way each
of those clauses, in turn,
got to be true in this
particular satisfying
assignment--
because you're going to pick
one true literal every clause.
And now, from that choice of
literals-- one per clause--
I'm going to look at the
corresponding nodes in G,
and I'm going to claim that
those nodes taken together
form a k-clique.
OK, so first of all, do they
have the right number of nodes?
Well, sure, because I'm
picking one node per clique.
I already said k is
the number of cliques,
so I'm getting exactly k nodes.
So I have at least the
right number of nodes.
But how do I know they're
all connected to one another,
those nodes that I just picked?
Well, they're all
connected to each other
because I'm going to say--
well, because there were no
forbidden edges among them.
And remember that we put in
all possible edges except
for the forbidden ones.
So how do I know there
are no forbidden edges?
Well, what were the rules
for being forbidden?
It means they-- two nodes
in the same clique--
in the same clause.
Well, I'm picking
one node per clause,
so I can never be having two
nodes from the same clause.
So I'm never going
to run into trouble
with the first condition
of being forbidden.
So what's the second
possibility for being forbidden,
is that I'm picking two nodes
which are inconsistent--
well, how do I know
that I didn't end up
with two nodes with
inconsistent labels?
That would be bad, because
then they would have
a forbidden edge, and what--
my result would not be a clique.
How do I know I didn't
end up picking--
in this group I pick a, and
in this group I pick a bar?
Well, because they all came
from the same assignment.
They were all true
liberals in clauses.
It's not possible that a
was true in this clause
and a bar is true
in that clause,
because if a is true here,
a bar's got to be false.
It can't be the true
literal in this clause.
So I cannot have any
inconsistent nodes appearing
among the nodes of my clique.
And so they're not
in the same clause.
They're not inconsistent,
so the edge has to be there.
And that's going to be true
for every pair of nodes
in that clique--
in that group of nodes, and
that's why it's a clique.
So that proves one direction.
Now we still have to
prove the other direction,
because we have to say,
well, if G has a k-clique,
how do we know that
phi is satisfied?
So that's the reverse.
So let's just take any
k-clique that's in G.
And how do I know I can get from
that, a satisfying assignment
to the formula?
Good-- getting some good
questions here in the chat.
But let me just move on.
So proving the reverse--
the reverse direction,
assuming we have a k-clique--
take any such k-clique.
Now, first of all,
you observe that it's
got to have one node
in every clause.
It can't have two nodes
in the same clause
or zero nodes in a clause.
First of all, it can't have
two nodes in the same clause.
Why?
Well, because those nodes are
never connected to one another.
So they cannot be both
in the same clique,
because all the nodes in the
inner clique are connected
to one another.
By the way we constructed G,
nodes from the same clause are
not connected, so they cannot
appear in a clique together.
So there's going
to be at most one
node from every clause
appearing in this clique, but--
appearing in this clique.
But we also have-- we
know we have k nodes,
so that means, if there
is at most one per clause,
and we only have k clauses,
that means every clause has
got to have one.
If some clause is
missing a node,
then there's got to be some
other clause that has two.
So we know that every--
that this clique that
G has exactly one
node in every clause.
So how do we get from that
satisfying assignment?
So what we're going to do is
take the corresponding literals
that correspond to that one
node in that was in the clique,
take those liberals and set
those literals to be true,
which means setting the
variable to be true or setting--
if the literal was a
bar, then setting a
to be false, because you
want a bar to be true.
You want to set the
literals to be true.
Well, now we're setting--
there's one node
in each clause--
we're setting one literal--
the corresponding
literal-- true,
so that's going to set one
true literal in every clause.
So that means it's
going to be satisfying.
There's one thing that one
has to really be careful here
to double check--
to make sure that we're
doing this consistently,
that we're not being asked to
set a true and also a bar true,
because then that
would not be possible.
But a and a bar are not
connected, so it's--
we're never going to be trying
to set both a and a bar true.
If we're going to be
trying to set a true,
we're never going to
try to set a bar true,
because those are not--
a and a bar cannot be
in the same clique.
They're not connected
to each other.
OK?
So that is the argument.
And lastly, I claim--
we're not going to look
at this in detail--
that it's kind of obvious
that this reduction can
be done in polynomial time.
Namely, if I give
you that formula,
you can write out
that graph in--
pretty easily.
There's no hard work to be
done in writing out that graph
or counting up the
number of clauses.
So that's the proof that I
can reduce 3SAT to clique.
And it tells you also that, if
I could solve clique quickly,
then I can solve 3SAT quickly.
And this is the whole
point, because I
can convert now clique
problems to 3SAT problems.
No.
I'm sorry.
I got it backwards--
convert 3SAT problems
to clique problems.
So if I can solve clique easily,
then I can solve 3SAT easily.
I just showed a way of
converting these formulas
to graphs.
So that says, if I can
solve the graphs easily,
then I can solve
the formulas easily.
OK, why don't we turn to
some-- oh, question, check-in.
But we can now also--
I'll launch a
check-in, but we'll--
let's just see.
I'm seeing many,
many questions here,
which are actually what
my check-in is about.
I'll turn it back to you guys.
OK, so where did we
use the fact that we
have three literals per clause?
Does this thing just work
even if we had any number
of literals per clause?
What do you think?
We got a tight race here.
Truth is losing
out, unfortunately.
All right.
Oh, it's really
close, but still--
OK.
One more-- OK,
it's neck and neck.
OK, almost done--
10 seconds-- are we done here?
OK, that's it-- ending polling.
Yes, truth has won out.
Thank God.
Yeah, it works for
any size clause.
We didn't use the
fact that it's a 3CNF.
It could have been
any number here.
Well, we've got a--
I guess it's a plurality
here, though, not a majority.
Where did we use 3 in
any of these argument?
I didn't mention it.
Maybe you were imagining that
it's going to be part of it,
but 3 does not come into
this discussion at all.
If you think about how
it's-- why it's working,
even if we had--
one of these clauses
had 10 literals in it,
as long as k is the
number of clauses,
and we don't connect
any variable--
any literals internal to a
clause, this whole argument
is going to still work.
So please check that make.
Sure you understand
what's going on,
because I can see that
a good chunk of you
have not got this right.
So I got a good question here.
What if it's only
just one big clause--
so it's like the whole
formula's just one big OR.
So what does happen
in that case?
Good question--
so in that case--
suppose there's one big
clause with 100 literals.
That's the whole formula.
It's just a big OR.
So we know the formula's going
to be satisfiable, by the way,
obviously.
So if you look at
the corresponding G,
it's going to have 100
nodes, because there's
one for every literal.
None of them are going to
be connected to each other,
because they're all
in the same clause.
So it looks like we're going
to be in tough shape trying
to find a clique there, because
there's no edges at all.
Everything's forbidden.
But what is k? k is going
to be 1 in that case,
because there's only one clause.
And kind of a degenerate case,
but a clique with just one--
just a single node is--
counts as a one clique,
because it's just one node.
There's no need for
any edges at all.
It still counts as a clique.
So it'll still work out.
Let's see.
What else here?
That was kind of a fun
question that you asked me.
Thank you.
There are a lot of questions.
I think we're actually
pretty near the break also.
We'll just see.
Yeah.
Oh, many, many questions here--
so I think I'm going to
start the clock going down
for our, coffee break and I will
take some of these questions.
I'll try to answer some of
these questions-- oops--
try to answer some of
these questions afterward.
All right.
Good-- all right.
So I got a question
about making sure
why nodes don't have
inconsistent labels, if I
understand the
question correctly.
So I never put edges between
nodes with inconsistent labels.
That's the rule.
That's my construction.
I get to say how the
construction works.
So those two nodes with
inconsistent labels
can never be in the same
clique, because there's
no edge between them.
So I'm not sure that
answered the question there,
but that was--
let's see.
So we're getting
another question here.
Since any Boolean formula
can be converted to CNF,
does that mean--
is SAT polynomial time
reducible to clique as w--
[INAUDIBLE] time
reducible to clique,
but not for the reason that
any Boolean formula can be
converted to CNF, because
that conversion is going to be
an exponential
conversion in general--
the conversion to CNF.
So you have to be careful
about what we mean
by converting a formula to CNF.
So also getting question-- what
happens in the case of 1SAT?
Well, we didn't really
talk about 1SAT.
So the question is,
suppose there's only
a single literal per clause.
That's an interesting--
another sort of edge case here.
What happens under
those circumstances?
So there's only a single
literal per clause.
So you have to work
out what happens.
But in that case,
all the clauses just
have one literal in
them, and now they have--
when you have a 1CNF, so there's
only one literally per clause,
the only way that
can be satisfiable
is you have to make
each literal true,
because there's
no ORing anymore.
So every literal has to
be true in the assignment.
So that means you can never
have any consistent literals.
And that's the only case
when you would not have
an edge, because you're not--
the forbidden
condition won't happen
because you don't have more
than one node per clause.
Every clause is going to have
just a single node in it.
So it really comes
down to whether or not
you have an
inconsistently labeled--
inconsistent clauses.
I didn't explain that
super well, but it's--
the argument still
works, though.
You should check
it for yourself.
So this is a basic question.
How do we see that F
is polynomial time?
I'm not sure I want to spend
a lot of discussion on that.
The conversion from the
formula to the graph is kind
of a one-to-one--
every literal becomes a node.
The rule for when edges
are present-- it's
a very simple rule.
I'm not sure what more to say.
It seems pretty clear
that the conversion--
that reduction is
polynomial time computable.
If you wrote a
program to do that,
it would operate very quickly.
Is it possible for G to have
a k plus n clique, where
n is greater than 0?
Does that matter?
If you think about it, the
biggest possible clique
that this graph G
could have is k.
It could never have more
than a bigger clique,
because two nodes in the same
clause are never connected.
You only have k clauses.
So the answer is no,
you cannot have a--
bigger than a k-clique--
just not going to happen.
Does each clause need to have
the same number of literals?
I don't see why.
So question is, why are
we worrying about 3SAT,
since it didn't
seem to matter here?
There are other examples
where it does matter.
I'm actually not sure
if we'll see one or not,
but there are cases
where it does matter.
Let me just see if there's
any quick questions here.
Somebody's saying,
does-- do we have
to worry about there being a
polynomial number of literals?
So you have to think about
what that question means.
The size of the input, which
includes all of the literals,
is n.
So there's going to be,
at most, n literals,
because that's the size
of the input, at most,
in literals appearing.
So you don't have to worry
about that being polynomial,
because--
by the way, we're defining
the size of the input
is going to be, at
most, n literals.
I hope that's clear.
OK.
OK, so this is a good question.
When we talk about
polynomial time,
it's polynomial in
the representation
of the input, which is--
if you want to think
about it in terms of bits,
that's fine-- or whatever.
It's not going to matter if
you use some larger alphabet.
But the number of symbols
you need in your fixed size
alphabet, the number
of symbols you
need to write down
that input in whatever
your reasonable encoding
is is going to be n.
And it's going to be
polynomial in n, polynomial
in that length of the input.
So another question is,
does SAT reduce the 3SAT?
Yes.
That we will see.
SAT actually does polynomial
time reduce to 3SAT.
Not by converting to
an equivalent formula,
but by some more--
somewhat more involved
argument than that.
OK, why don't we move on?
Some of these are going to
come out anyway in the lecture.
OK, so now let's talk
about NP completeness,
because we've kind
of set things up.
We're not going to prove
that the basic theorem,
the Cook-Levin theorem
about NP completeness,
but at least we'll be able
to make the definition.
OK, here is our definition of
what it means for a problem
to be NP complete.
So a language B is
called the NP complete
if it has two properties.
Number one is that it
has to be a member of NP,
and number two--
every language in NP
has the polynomial time
reduce to that
language-- to that NP
complete language in order
for it to be NP complete.
So simple picture-- has
to be in NP and everything
an NP reduces to it.
And so that's kind of
the magical property
that we claim that SAT has.
sat, for one thing,
is obviously in NP.
And as we-- the
Cook-Levin theorem shows--
or will show-- everything
in NP is reducible to SAT,
so SAT's going to be our
first example of an NP
complete problem.
And we're going to get
what we claimed also
for SAT-- that, if SAT or
any other NP complete problem
turns out to be solvable
in polynomial time, then
every NP problem is
solvable in polynomial time.
And that's immediate,
because everything
is reducible in polynomial time
to the NP complete problem.
So if you can do it easily,
you can do everything easily
just by going through
the reduction.
OK.
So the Cook-Levin
theorem, as I mentioned,
is that SAT is NP complete.
And we're going to actually
prove it next lecture,
but let's assume for the
remainder of this lecture
that we know it to be true.
So I'll use the terminology
of problems being NP complete,
assuming that we know--
that we have SAT as NP complete.
OK?
So we're going to be
using some of the things
that we're proving next
lecture just in the terminology
that we're going to
be talking today.
OK, so here's the picture.
Here's the class NP.
And everything in NP is
polynomial time reducible
to SAT.
SAT itself is a
member of NP, but I
didn't want to show it that way
because it makes the picture
kind of hard to display.
So just from the perspective of
the reduction, everything in NP
is polynomial time
reducible to SAT.
We'll show that next lecture.
Another thing that
we'll show next lecture
is that SAT, in turn,
is polynomial time
reducible to 3SAT.
So 3SAT, as you remember,
are just those problems
that are in conjunct--
are in 3CNF.
And then what we show today is
that 3SAT is polynomial time
reducible to clique.
So now, taking the assumption
that SAT is NP complete--
so everything is polynomial
time reduce both the SAT, which
is, in turn, polynomial time
reducible to 3SAT, and in turn,
reducible to clique.
These reductions, as we've
seen before, composed.
You can just apply one reduction
function after the next.
If each one individually
is polynomial,
the whole thing as a combination
is going to be polynomial.
So now we know
that 3SAT is going
to be also NP complete, because
we can reduce anything in NP
to SAT, and then
to 3SAT, and then
we get a reduction
directly to 3SAT
by composing those
two reductions--
and then, furthermore,
at the clique.
So now we're-- have several
NP complete problems.
And moving beyond that, we have
the HAMPATH problem, which we
are going to talk about next.
And we'll show another
reduction in addition
to the one we just
showed to clique, now one
going from 3SAT to HAMPATH.
OK.
So in general, I think
the takeaway message is
that, to show some
language is NP complete,
you want to show that
3SAT is polynomial time
reducible to it.
OK, some good
questions coming in--
I'll try to answer those.
So you're going to take
3SAT and reduce to C.
That's the most typical case.
There's going to be
other examples too,
we might start with
another problem
that you've already shown
to be in NP complete,
and reduce it to your language.
So it doesn't have to start with
3SAT, though often, it does.
Why is this concept important?
So I would say there
are two reasons.
And this is going
to get a little bit
at some of the chat questions.
First of all, if you're faced
with some new computational
problem-- you've got some
robotics problem that you want
to solve in your thesis, and
you need some algorithm about
whether the robot
arm can do such--
move in a certain such a
way, and involves searching--
possibly searching through
a space of different kinds
of motions, and
you want to know--
I'd like to find a
polynomial algorithm
to solve that problem.
I'm using this as an example
because this actually
did happen to one of
the former students
from this class, who
was working in robotics,
and they actually end up proving
that the problem that they were
trying to solve is NP complete.
So that's useful
information, because even
though knowing a
problem is NP complete
doesn't guarantee
that it's not in P--
because conceivably,
P equals NP--
what it does tell you--
if you have a problem
that's NP complete
and it does turn out to
be in P, then P equals NP.
So there would be tremendous
surprising consequences
of your problem, if it was known
to be NP complete, ending up
in P. So generally,
people take a proof of NP
completeness as
powerful evidence
that the problem is not in
P. Even though it's not quite
a proof, it's powerful
evidence that it's not in P.
And so you might as
well give up working
on trying to find a
polynomial algorithm for it,
because if you do, you
don't have to worry
about robotics anymore.
You're going to become famous
as a So I wouldn't worry about--
so if you throw
problem's NP complete,
you can pretty much assume--
almost certainly not
in P. Now, there's
another reason related to--
for the theorists to be--
care about NP completeness,
and that is, if you're trying to
prove P is different from NP--
or P equals NP, as one of the
chat questions is raising--
order to prove P different from
NP, the most likely approach
is you pick some
[? pre ?] problem in NP
and show it's not in P.
That's what it would mean
for them to be different.
You're going to
pick some NP problem
and show it's not a P problem.
Well, one thing would
be terrible is possibly,
P is different from NP, and
you pick the wrong problem.
Suppose I'd spent all
my time trying to show--
back 20 years ago,
I'm working really
hard trying to show
composites is not
in P, which is-- would have
been perfectly reasonable to do,
because composites is
an NP, and it was not
known to be in P 20 years ago.
And then I invested
tons of effort
to try to prove-- because I
like number theory or God knows
what-- to prove that
composites is not in P.
And then, turns
out, composites was
in P. It was the
wrong problem to pick,
even though P might
be different from NP.
But what NP complete
is guarantees
is that, if you work on a
problem, which is NP complete,
you can't pick
the wrong problem,
because if any problem
is in NP, and not in P,
an NP complete problem is going
to be an example of that--
because if the NP complete
problems in P, everything in NP
is in P.
So if NP is
different from P, you
know the complete
problems are not in P,
so you might as well
work on one of those.
So those are two ways in which
NP completeness has turned out
to be-- is an important concept.
OK, so here's a check-in.
You guys are getting--
maybe you're getting-- starting
to think the way I think.
You're getting-- some--
at least one of you asked
this question in the chat.
Which language
are we've probably
seen is most analogous to SAT--
ATM, ETM, or 0 to
the k, 1 to the k?
Obviously, this is
maybe subjective.
You may have your
own interpretation
of what that means.
There's, in a sense,
perhaps no right answer,
but what do you think?
OK, that's it.
I don't know how in
the world that you
could see this problem as
analogous to 0 to the k, 1
to the k, but OK.
I'm sure you have your reason.
Yes, this is a lot like ATM.
Why?
well, because for one thing,
we showed in a homework problem
that all Turing
recognizable languages
are reducible to ATM--
mapping reducible to ATM.
So that's a little bit like
the notion of completeness
that we have for satisfiability,
because all NP problems are
going to be
reducible to the SAT.
And the other thing too
is that, once we start--
we want to show other
problems are undecidable,
we reduced ATM to them.
And that's also very similar.
We're going to be
reducing SAT or 3SAT--
so it's indirectly from SAT--
to other problems
in order to show
that there shouldn't
NP complete,
so that they're hard--
that they're hard, in a sense.
And so in both those
ways, ATM and SAT
are kind of playing
similar roles.
One key difference,
however, between ATM and SAT
is in that for ATM, we can
prove that it's undecidable,
but for SAT, we don't
know how to prove
it's outside of P. Those would
be the analogous situations.
And so the story for
SAT, which is easily
solved by a diagonalization
argument for ATM--
there's reasons to believe--
that we will see later--
that the diagonalization is
not going to work to prove SAT
outside of P. And besides
that, we don't really
have any good methods.
So anyway, let's move on.
Why is ETM less analogous?
Because the ATM was the first
problem we showed undecidable,
and SAT is the first
problem that we're going
to be showing NP complete.
I guess that would be my answer.
OK, let's continue.
So let's show now that
HAMPATH is NP complete,
assuming that we know SAT
or 3SAT is NP complete.
So we're going to give a
reduction from 3SAT to HAMPATH.
That's what this is about.
It's just like what we did for
clique, but now for HAMPATH.
And this is going
to be very typical.
In these reductions,
typically what
happens is that you're trying
to simulate a formula--
Boolean formula for
satisfiability--
from the satisfiability
perspective.
You're trying to
simulate that formula
with some sort of structures
inside the target language,
which would be HAMPATH.
The lingo that people
use is that you're
going to build
gadgets to simulate
the structures in the formula--
namely, the variables, the
literals, and the clauses.
OK, these are going to be
substructures of the graph,
in this case, that
you're building.
We'll see what that means.
So let's take a formula
here and let's, again,
try to imagine how
we would reduce that
to the HAMPATH problem.
So the reduction would
produce a graph--
no, it would produce an HAMPATH
instance-- so a G, s, and t.
Want to know, is there a
Hamiltonian path from s
to t in the graph?
And this is going to
be not the whole graph,
but this is going to be a
substructure in that graph.
The next slide is going to
have the global structure
of the graph.
But here, this is going
to be a key element,
and we're going to call
that the variable gadget.
OK, what does it look like?
I don't know if you
can see it on your--
clearly enough,
but these edges--
so there are four
outside nodes here.
The edges connecting them are
all kind of pointed downward.
And then there were these
horizontal nodes here,
and there are edges
connecting them
both left to right and to left.
There's a row of these
horizontal nodes.
OK, so you get the picture
of what this looks like?
You have to look carefully
to see the arrowheads.
I maybe should have made
those a little bigger.
Whoops-- so now, if we're trying
to get from this node to that
node--
imagine now you're trying
to build a Hamiltonian path,
because this is going to
be a part of that graph G
that I'm constructing.
Now, remember, for
them-- for there
to be a Hamiltonian
graph, that means
you have to go through
every node in the graph.
So if I want to get from
s to t, the only way
I'm going to be able to go-- to
hit these horizontal nodes here
is by picking them up
as I go from s to t.
So the only possibility is--
if you think about it, is--
would be for the sequence to
go like this, if you can--
if that comes through for you.
So the path would go
from s to this node,
and then through these hops of--
along these horizontal nodes,
and then down to the bottom
node here.
So that's one way that you can
get from here down to there
and pick up all the other
nodes along the way, which
is-- they're not going to
have any other possibility--
possible ways of
getting to them.
So I'm going to
call that a zig-zag.
OK?
But there's another
way to get from s
to the bottom node,
which is going to be
by doing sort of the dual--
going to the right, then
going out to the left,
and then down to the bottom.
I'm going to call
that a zig-zig--
and with a little
diagram here just
to summarize what it means.
And this is the classic
thing for a variable gadget,
because it's a
structure that when
you're trying to think about how
the object that you're asking
whether it exists or not--
the Hamiltonian path-- how
it relates to that object,
it's going to have two
possibilities, which
are going to correspond
to the variable being set
true or false in the formula.
So we're showing
how to set the--
simulate the variable in
this HAMPATH instance.
So setting the variable
is going to correspond
to constructing the path.
OK?
Now, we also have to make sure
not only that the variable gets
set to true or false, but that
it gets a set of true and false
in a way that makes this a
satisfying assignment-- namely,
that we get one true
literal in every clause.
So I'm going to add
another gadget here called
a clause gadget, which
is just a single node.
And visiting that
node here is going
to correspond to
satisfying that clause,
to having a true
literal in that clause.
I'm going to have
[? enabled ?] a detour
from these horizontal nodes
out to this clause gadget.
So here it is.
Here's that detour.
As I'm going from left to
right, I can-- instead of
doing a single jump
here, I could branch out
and visit that clause
node, and then come back,
and pick up my left to right
path, as I was doing before.
I hope you're seeing
the big picture,
because this has to
be a Hamiltonian path.
It has to hit every node.
That's one of the requirements.
This is going to be one
of the nodes in my graph.
The path has got
to hit that node.
The only way it's going to
be able to hit that node
is by taking a detour off of
this horizontal path here.
But notice-- and
this is the key--
if I'm doing a zig-zag, then I
can make the detour and visit
that clause gadget--
that clause node.
But if I'm doing a zag-zig, the
way this detour is structured
does not allow me
to visit that node,
because if I'm going
from to right left here,
by the time I get to
this outgoing edge--
now I want to come back--
that note has
already been taken.
It only works if
I'm going zag-zig,
if I'm going from
right to left--
left to right.
If I'm going from left to
right, then I can do it,
but if I'm going
right to left, no.
If you think of left--
the left to right
direction as true,
that's going to correspond
to that variable appearing
in the positive
way in that clause,
but not in the negative way.
The negative way-- I
would reverse in and out
of the detour, flip
that around so now
I could only do the detour
when I'm going right to left,
instead of left to right.
I hope you get the picture.
This is how the
structure is working.
Now what's only left for me
to do is put it all together.
But this slide contains the
guts of what's happening.
Is there any question that I
can answer for you on this?
Let's move on to the next slide,
and then, as questions come up,
you can be typing them in, and
we can maybe answer it there.
OK, so here is the big picture.
So imagine we have that
formula that we're start--
we're reducing that formula.
And let's say it has m
variables and k clauses.
I'm going to call them
clause c1, c2, up to ck--
here, the m variables
appearing either positively
or negated in that formula.
And this is the way the
global structure of G
is going to look like.
Now, I'm getting
a question here.
What do those horizontal
nodes-- what role do they play?
Those nodes are there to
allow me to visit those clause
nodes, the nodes which represent
the clause gadgets, which
I'm going to place over here.
This is almost a whole of G.
I'm just missing a few edges,
but these are all
the nodes of G.
So remember, I'm
trying to find out,
is there a Hamiltonian
path from s to t?
Now, if I didn't have to
worry about these nodes,
the answer would be just yes.
In fact, there would be many
Hamiltonian paths from s to t,
because I can do a
zig-zag or a zig-zag
through each of these
variable gadgets,
and that would take me from
s to t, and I'd be good.
It's just the c nodes, these
nodes-- these ci nodes--
I have to hit them too.
So they're going to be--
visiting them is going to be
enabled by detours from here.
So let me just try to show
you what that looks like.
So I'm going to magnify little
pieces here from these gadgets
here and show you how these
guys are connected up.
So here is the x1 gadget.
So x1 appears positively in c1.
Here's x1 and c1.
And so that means, when
I'm going left to right,
I'm going to be a
possibility of visiting c1.
But now, let's look
what happens with--
which was the next
one I had here?
OK.
Right.
So the next one is-- oh, yeah.
So x1 appears positively in c1.
That's why I have the
connection like this.
Now, x1 appears negated in
c2, so I only want to do--
enable the detour
to visit c2 when
I'm going to left, as
opposed to left to right.
So this set of
horizontal nodes is only
going to allow me to take
a detour either out to c1
or out to c2, but not to
both, because the Hamiltonian
path is either going to go
left or right or to left.
It can't do both, when it's
going through the x1 gadget.
You need to--
[INAUDIBLE] I'll try
to help you through it,
but you have to try to think
about why it's working.
Let's think together.
So x2 also appears in c1,
but now it appears negated.
So I'm going to have edges
from this x2 gadget--
oops-- the x2 gadget, but
now look at the-- look
at how I've arranged
that detour.
I can leave on the
left leftward side
and return on the
right side, which
means I can only do that
detour when I'm going to left.
And that's because
x2 is negated in c1.
Maybe it's a lot here, if
you're not quite getting it,
but the point is, let's say,
try to quickly prove-- so that's
the whole construction.
You just do that for
every single appearance
of the literal in a clause.
You're going to add
these detours, which
allow you possibly to
go visit the clause.
So the forward direction is--
why is this true?
So you take any satisfying
assignment, as I suggested,
make the corresponding
zig-zags or zag-zigs
through the variable
gadgets from s
to t, and then take the detours
to visit the clause nodes.
The reverse direction
actually is slightly trickier.
We're not going to have time to
go through the subtlety of it,
but what you want
to make sure here
is that you don't have a weird
path occurring, because I'm
going to start with
a Hamiltonian path
now and build an assignment.
And we want to make sure that
the path that I'm constructing
doesn't go from one--
from this horizontal nodes
to a closed node, and then
back to somebody else's
horizontal nodes, and is kind
of a hodgepodge of things which
don't make any sense in trying
to reconstruct a satisfying
assignment.
What you really
want to have happen
is the Hamiltonian path
should have clear zig-zags
and zags-zigs that
allow you to decide
how to set the variables.
And so that's the role of
these little nodes here.
These are spacers that separate
the detours from one another,
and that force a visit
to the clause node
to come back to the same
place from which it left.
Otherwise, you would never
be able to visit those spacer
nodes.
You have to look in
the book for that,
but there is a little
bit of a detail
that you have to go through.
You have to show it must
be zig-zags and zag-zigs,
and then you get the
corresponding truth assignment,
and it must satisfy
phi for all paths.
OK.
Again, the reduction is
polynomial time computable.
I'm not going to
say more about that.
We're a little bit low on time.
Last check-in-- would
this construction still
work if G was undirected?
Suppose I just eliminated all
the directions from the edges,
made them lines,
instead of arrows.
Would that now show that the
undirected Hamiltonian path
problem is NP complete?
Let me see.
OK, what do the c
nodes represent here?
There's one c node
for every clause.
So there are k clauses named c1
to ck, and there are k c nodes.
These are the so-called
clause gadgets,
which are going to
force there to be
one true literal in every clause
for the satisfying assignment.
You have to look at it, or maybe
we can spend a little bit more
time explaining it, but
that's what the purpose is.
Does that mean we need
only two inside nodes?
So the horizontal nodes--
do we only need two of them?
You won't be able to reuse these
nodes for multiple detours.
For one thing, once
you've gone to a detour,
you come back to the node
next over, and so you better
not overlay multiple detours.
And also, you need to keep
them separated from each other.
Don't forget, this
node x1 can appear
in many, many different
clauses, so you
would need to have possibly
many of these horizontal nodes.
So someone now says 2k
inside nodes would suffice.
Probably 2k-- I would
say 3k, just to be
safe for the spacer nodes.
You need to look carefully
at the argument, which
is laid out in the textbook.
You may not actually
need the spacer nodes,
but then it makes the
argument just more ugly.
So the way the
construction is done
is you have 3k inside nodes.
OK.
Again, several
questions like that--
the graph would start looking
messy if x9 was in c1.
Yeah, if x9 down here was in c1?
Yeah, it would be messy.
It's OK.
Messy is allowed.
All right, I think we're--
let's end the polling.
Are you all in?
All right-- share results.
Yes.
The answer's no.
The construction depends
on this being directed.
You can see that all over
the place, but for one thing,
the whole point of these detours
is the directions of the edges.
And so without that,
this construction
is going to be just a bunch of--
is not going to mean anything.
It's not going to
prove anything.
It's probably
always going to be--
have a Hamiltonian path
without the directions.
So I think we're out of time.
A quick review-- these are
the topics we've covered.
I think we're out of time,
so I should let you go.
But I'll stick around for a
few minutes, in case any of you
have any questions.
But I need to run off at 4:00
myself for another meeting,
so I don't have
much that much time.
Clarify my comment about
picking the wrong problem
to tackle P versus NP, when I
used composites as an example--
if I worked hard to prove
that composites is not
in P as a way of proving that
there is some NP language which
is not in P, that would
have been a mistake,
because composites
is in P. I would
have been working hard to
prove something which we now
know was false.
So we don't want to spend time
working on the wrong language.
But the nice thing about
NP complete languages
is that we have a guarantee
that, if P's different from NP,
that that language is
not in P. Are there
problems that are not
in P that are in NP,
but are not NP complete?
Oh, that's a good question.
Are there problems in
between P and NP complete?
So NP complete is sort of like
the hardest problems in NP,
and the P problems are
obviously the easy problems
that are in NP.
Is everything either
NP complete or in P?
So for one thing, there
are problems that are not
known to be in either category.
So we'll discuss some of those
in due course, but one of them
is the graph
isomorphism problem,
testing two graphs-- if they're
really just permutations of one
another.
It's clearly a problem in
NP, but not known to be in P.
So there are
problems that are not
known to be either
NP complete or in P,
so there are problems
that might be in between.
But then there was
another theorem
out there, which says that,
if you assume that P is differ
from NP, then you can construct
problems which are in between,
which are neither NP complete
nor in P. They're NP, problems
but they're not NP complete,
not in P. So those problems
themselves are perhaps
somewhat artificial,
but they at least
prove the point
that it is possible to have
these intermediate problems.
Oh, so somebody's asking,
isn't factorization one.
Not [? known-- ?] for the
case of factorization--
or you have to make a language
out of that, by the way.
But it's a because
factorization's a function,
so we won't really want to
be talking about languages.
As the homework suggests, NP
and P are classes of languages,
but OK, that's a
separate note there.
Factorization is not known.
Factorization could be in P
and it could be NP complete.
Both of those are not ruled out.
So I think most
people would probably
venture to guess that
it's a problem that's
in the in-between state, that's
neither P nor NP complete,
but not known.
Who first thought of this
reduction from 3SAT to HAMPATH?
It's so clever.
Well, it wasn't me.
I think that is due
to Dick Karp, who
was one of my professors
at Berkeley, where
I was a graduate student.
That was done
before I got there.
It was around 1971 when--
so there were two famous papers.
There's the Cook paper.
There's also the Levin paper.
That was in Russian.
That took a while for people to
discover out here in the West.
But the Cook paper was 1971, and
very quickly followed after--
he just showed SAT
is NP complete,
but after that, Karp was--
he had a paper
called "Reducibility
Among Combinatorial
Problems," and he
had a list of about
20 problems that he
showed were NP complete--
by reduction from SAT--
include clique, include HAMPATH,
and a bunch of other things.
And that was also a
very famous paper.
Both of those are--
people often talk
about Cook-Karp
as, together, they really
show the importance
of NP completeness and the
whole notion of NP completeness.
Yeah, 21 problems, so--
yeah, so Karp proved 21
when problems were NP
complete in 1972.
So that was shortly
after Cook showed
that SAT was NP complete.
Incidentally, I think the
terminology NP complete wasn't
around until a little later.
And that might have been--
might be due to Knuth.
I'm not sure.
I remember he did a
big poll of people
about what should be the right
language to use for that term,
and I think he came up with it.
All right, I'm going
to head off, guys.
Nice seeing you all--
so until Thursday--
oh, until Tuesday.
Bye bye.